Come shopping with me for spooky stuff at Marshall's Home Goods!
I never get to do things like this
because I usually have a toddler with me
and I love Halloween. The first thing I spotted though,
was this discarded sweater that I'm definitely gonna pick up.
It was meant to be.
Now my daughter is having a Wednesday Addams themed 10th birthday
and I wanted to get some of these really cute sparkly pillows.
How cute would those be for her little glamping sleepover tents?
They were kind of on the pricey side,
so I only got a couple. They were each 2999.
They also had all of their pumpkins out of every type of decoration,
but I was really drawn to Medusa.
But I definitely brought home Medusa.
Next I found some really cute clothes that I wanted to try on
because again, I never get to try on clothes.
I always online shop. I loved these two pieces.
They were both statement pieces,
but together with a pair of sneakers they're absolutely wearable.
I loved the netting on the top.
It's from house of Harlow.
It definitely reminded me of the sixties.
And speaking of the 60s, here was another house of Harlow dress.
This one was not quite perfect.
The fit just wasn't there.
I was heading to Utah, so I really wanted a denim dress,
but this one just did not have the right cut.
But the metallic skirt and top definitely made it.
Then I scooted over to the bag aisle
because look at these adorable themed bags for Halloween.
I can't describe it, but something like this just gives me so much joy.
And I saw somebody wearing this out.
I would just die.
They also had some loungeflies and some Harry Potter stuff,
which I was really surprised by
because I don't usually shop at Marshalls. Again,
I don't get to shop in person a lot.
I almost got this loungefly cause it was only $40,
which is. But then I saw these real leather bags.
They smelled incredible. And if you know about real leather,
you know that you can smell the difference.
I was shocked by the price point and the quality.
But if you wanna know what actually made it home with me,
I was looking for a side table for my office,
and this macaroon table definitely came home.
Such a random basket, but such a fun trip to Marshalls.